they've provided the soundtrack to our
lives for decades giving a voice to
Canadian stories and singing songs we
will never forget from coast-to-coast
they have managed to give us music that
has bound us together and has told our
stories without sounding cheesy about
it all began in Kingston's club scene in
the mid 80s the hit played gig after gig
trying to make their mark in the music
industry the band is phenomenal but to
watch court perform and I've ever seen
him on SNL years ago and this guy he's
so cool
and although they never broke into
America they quickly became Canada's
best kept secret Canadians have actually
looked at this and gone okay America you
don't know what you're missing out so
we're gonna wrap our arms around this
bed even tighter with nine number one
albums and 14 Juno Awards the band
became a national treasure picking up a
Governor General's Award in 2008 it's
just not something you ever really
imagined
Gort down is the best frontman maybe
that's at Canada's ever had
he's one of I think Canada's most
important icons for us it's it's it's
just to keep moving forward and keep
creating
but I made 24th of this year the band
drops a bombshell sending shockwaves
through the entire country we have some
very tough news to share with you in
December
gore Downey was diagnosed with terminal
brain cancer for Downey's spring tumor
is incurable the whole country just kind
of had this collective freakout no this
can't be happening this is right it's
not fair
but in true iconic hip style Gord isn't
giving up the band announces they'll go
on tour and it sells out in seconds you
know knowing Gord that way is yeah he
was like yeah you know I want to go play
these songs for people
with his shimmering suit and signature
moves everyone's favorite frontman
returns to the stage full of life and
the entire nation has his back if I'm
them and I'm looking at all this I'm
saying oh my god we had this kind of
effect on several generations of people
all across our country Wow staying true
to their roots the band will return to
Kingston for a final farewell tomorrow
night and we'll be there it is the last
one it's in the hometown and the band
has this opportunity to end it on their
terms so let's start the bidding now
what will be their last song whatever it
is there's no doubt Saturday's show will
go down in history
you